[Musique]
il est 19h quatrième quand sandrine
rousseau candidate à la primaire
écologiste remercie jean pierre bel
mandeau d'avoir porté haut le cinéma
français et elle ajoute une touche
d'humour noir en espérant que sa
dernière cascades n'aura pas été trop
difficile tollé sur la toile l'écolo
supprime son tweet et republié à 19h17
un autre message à l'attention cette
fois de jean paul belmondo tout en
conservant sa blague rto les ai reçus
pression du tweet sandrine rousseau en
restera là et on invitera ludovic
obraniak de l'équipe parce que lui aussi
n'est pas très au point enfin lui non
plus sur bébel il était question du film
le professionnel et sa bo culte vous
décevoir un petit peu mais mon rapport
c'est pas générationnel pour moi
belmondo donc pour moi la musique ont
entendu tout à l'heure c'est royal canin
et on referme
ainsi que jean paul belmondo il était
comme certains acteurs depardieu entre
autres qui devait péter à ma vente avant
de jouer à l'est mais tout à coup une
rafale de paix tout le monde attendait
et après tout ah oui et le cadeau rôle
c'était fantastique mais lorsqu'il
n'était il mettait pas les gens mal à
l'aise c'est bizarre de prouver son
inspiration dans d'expiration à se
lâcher c'est la vie
après plus de soixante jours de
mobilisation la plupart des cheminots de
la gare de lyon ont repris le travail
même leur leader et je le dis avec
conviction mais un problème technique
évident sur ce sujet qu'il n'avait aucun
rapport avec jean paul belmondo
belmont d'or
et non destinée movistar et non
gestionnaires à ben hamman et chauffeurs
et receveurs down by heidi charisme à
websense su pas cool
dès qu'il ya pierre niney la fiche je
vais voir le film sans même savoir ce
que c'est et je ne suis jamais déçu
jamais mais on aura une petite fois mais
dans tous les registres que ce soit
comique que ce soit tragique que ce soit
amoureux ou non quoi c'est toujours
formidable vous allez donc à doha partir
maintenant que l'invasion qu'après ça
peut que
[Rires]
redescendre à louis député la république
en marche collaboratrice de marlène
schiappa ah oui alors je vais vous
laisser là
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est la science et la santé la
distance est l'absent sont là sans ces
gens sont la santé son rasoir
j'ai entendu et ce que je vous réponds
que je dis n'importe quoi c'est
absolument désagréable puisque je
pourrais regarder sur quel site on
n'avait jamais vu ça sur la chaîne lci
des embardées on va regarder
[Rires]
qu'à naples une retraitée se présente
dans un bureau de tabac et achètent de
tiken un jeu à gratter le premier ne
donne rien mais en grattant le deuxième
bingo un gain de 500 mille euros la
petite dame n'arrive pas à y croire
alors elle demande à l'employé derrière
le comptoir de vérifier ce dernier
appelle son patron le buraliste qui
pratiquait en main mais au lieu de le
rendre à la retraitée il attrape son
casque saute sur son scooter voilà il
disparaît la police immédiatement
alertés mais trop tard le buraliste a
pris la fuite avec l'united center et le
monde dans ce bon alors on va gagner du
temps vous aimeriez bien oui
[Rires]
entre temps l'organisme des jeux
d'argent a gelé les gains liés à tous
les tickets du bureau de tabac concernés
et l'histoire a pris fin hier quand la
police a annoncé l'arrestation du
fugitif à rome il était sur le point
d'embarquer sur un vol en direction des
canaris n'a quant au ticket gagnant et
bien il avait pris le temps de le
déposer dans une banque où il comptait
en fait encaisser son gain plus tard
quand les choses se seraient un peu
calmé le deux amateurs de bonne foi aux
escrocs bois même
arrêter d'être le tout tout tout tout je
suis en train de vous n'y avez pas le
président intelligent pour comprendre je
dédie répète 75 % des français sont
doublement
25% l'hôpital pour être longue à venir
que de 60 pour espionner
c'est que je connaisse c'est la
prochaine fois que je retourne encore
c'est le plus beau garçon de sa
génération de sa génération franchement
vous sur clerc
[Musique]
adorable et en plus il joue comme un
dieu il est convaincant dans toutes les
émotions il est extraordinaire
c'est quoi non mais ma vraie la pièce
yahia avons eu le plaisir de jouer
dehors vous ce soir et de ivan rioufol
et de jérôme béglé les décors sont
déroger à voir et écouter ça fait
cinquante mille fois alors attention ou
de l'amélioration continue
il très courte enquête visant à évaluer
votre niveau de capital à faire
c'est super
bien qu'on a qu'on en arrive à des
insultes sur le plat il sait pas d un
succès des jeux vous propose que vous
vous battiez
de jeu blessé dont j'essaie je vous
propose mes amis je vous propose que
vous régliez ça sur le pré
i
[Musique]
c'est du taureau vous avez sous vos yeux
monsieur
mais tout va bien ça se mange on espère
qu'on lui souhaite cherry situe même et
tu me cuir et des nouilles et pendant
qu'elle accueillerait tu me tripote
alors il vous reste 7 minutes pour
trouver le mot le plus long on va
réfléchir ok que quelque chose que avec
que ok déjà qu tu ne mets en tant
qu eux et rockets pour acura saisie par
acura comment ça s'écrit coudes
pour quelles raisons achetons une montre
intelligente banque uniquement pour le
sport non pour donner l'heure par
exemple un bateau
oui mais
bien
comment soulager
et aidez moi eh bien on à kano et déjà
on a un mode sûr mais ce que j'aurais
essayé bah c'est fini quoi
[Musique]